des forces spéciales hostiles se sont
introduites dans le port de cette petite
localité
les conscrits et réservistes ont pour
mission de les neutraliser le scénario
est fictif policiers militaires civils
depuis quelques années l'armée
finlandaise organise au moins tous les
deux ans ce type d'exercice dans les
différentes régions du pays une manière
d'être préparé à toute éventualité
la guerre en ukraine n'a pas influencé
le programme cette année mais ici on
reconnaît que le contexte est
particulier
on se trouve en ce moment environ 70 km
de la russie pays avec lequel la
finlande partage une frontière de plus
de 1300 km la guerre en ukraine a ravivé
le débat sur la relation entretenir avec
le voisin russe mais aussi avec le temps
une alliance militaire dont la finlande
ne fait pas partie united a fondé
[Musique]
en 1939 le pays a été attaqué par
l'union soviétique qui a subi
d'importantes pertes dans les décennies
qui ont suivi la deuxième guerre
mondiale la finlande a voulu se tenir à
l'écart des rivalités entre la russie et
l'occident l'approché landaise
collaborer sans adhérer formellement à
l'otan une politique qui pourrait
changer radicalement faudra 3 et 2
benabbad
dans les rues d'helsinki certains
reconnaissent que le contexte n'est plus
le même tu est intacte
ils ont attaqué l'ukraine l'europe dit
cet homme cette finlandaise d'origine
russe très critique du kremlin hésite
elle se demande s'ils se joindre à
l'alliance militaire est l'option la
plus sécuritaire
a deux noms surtout que la russie a
récemment menacé la finlande et la suède
qui n'est pas non plus membre de l'otan
s'est dit avec l'organisation ne se fera
pas sans conséquences a averti le
kremlin il faut rester comme il faut
être vraiment finlandais parce que on a
maintenant un précédent vachement
agressive vladimir poutine donc on ne
sais pas qu'est ce qu'il va faire donc
il faut pas avoir une autre clash notre
conflit ici en finlande ou en soit m cet
ancien premier ministre favorable depuis
longtemps à une adhésion à le temps
demande aux dirigeants finlandais de
prendre leur temps mais selon lui la
pression populaire pourrait finir par
avoir raison des réserves des y du
réfractaire la situation de sécurité en
europe a complètement changé et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut avoir un allié
analystes situation sécuritaire et je
crois que la population finlandaise
vraiment peur plus au nord loin des
débats politiques on se concentre sur le
bon déroulement des exercices
une mise à jour importante selon ce
réserviste qui n'avait pas pris les
armes depuis une dizaine d'années
situés en europe chose
mais
la finlande n'est pas en ce moment
menaces et de conflit mais il craint que
son pays paisible d'europe du nord ne
soit plus à l'abri si raphaël boudy
auclair radio-canada à joensuu en
finlande